es un trabajo que ha durado ya por años
hemos trabajado acá en el estado para
tratar de cambiar a verdad el condado de
gwinnett es un gran ejemplo donde
empezamos hace 10 años bien abajo pero
ya el cambio estaba viniendo y se estaba
viendo por tiempo
y trabajamos bien duro para asegurarnos
que todas las personas en el condado
salieran a votar esta precie elección
verdad ha sido bien importante para
nuestra comunidad especialmente contando
que ha en el estado como tal hay
alrededor de un millón de hispanos
y de es de esos la mitad estaban
registradas están elegibles a votar
y hemos aumentado en nuestra en nuestros
números de votantes verdad si vemos hace
15 años habían alrededor de 30.000 a
latinos registrado votar ya hoy por día
estamos a 300.000 latinos a nivel del
estado ahí es algo que hemos tratado
tratando de trabajar y claro está que
tenemos un presidente que no
ha atacado como comunidad y creo que
esta elección
dio a luz verdad que a nuestra comunidad
está unida y vamos a luchar para
adelante y asegurarnos nuestra
representación así sea la que
necesitamos señor molina algunos
consideran electoralmente a la comunidad
hispana en eeuu como el gigante dormido
usted coincide
completamente yo te es interesante que
estas palabras porque yo servía en la
naval de los estados unidos
acordamos
en la guerra mundial número 2 verdad
cuando los eeuu dentro fue por robert y
en esos tiempos
el imperio japonés perdió a un general
que dijo a wi-fi del acuífero no busquen
the sleeping en verdad nuestra comunidad
acá en realidad vino a trabajar vino a
asegurarnos que nuestras familias
tuvieran un mejor futuro y donald trump
por medio de sus retóricas y sus
acciones ha levantado a este gigante que
está en nuestra comunidad y por eso
hemos visto un incremento en el nivel de
votación de nuestra comunidad y creo que
va a ser algo que va a continuar porque
la realidad es que hay bastantes votos
especialmente durante dentro de nuestra
comunidad a más jóvenes ya estamos
hablando de 18 29 años que ha salido a
votar y que en mi mente creo que
continuarán haciéndolo así que estamos
hablando de un gran cambio es importante
recalcar que cae en gwinnett verdad ya
que estamos hablando de gwinnett
y más del 51 por ciento de todos los
estudiantes en el condado son impactos
muy bien antonio molina muchas gracias
por esta comunicación por tu respuesta
lee el es ex presidente del caucus
latino por el partido demócrata de
georgia y actualmente miembro del comité
latinos con bailén